this is uh brings us to the silver medal
winner in narrative films and this is
another american film institute graduate
ryan Prowse has made narcocorrido which
is that's well and it's not easy to say
saying I'm from Indiana so naco corrido
I can't roll it like I wish I could but
it's based around a ballad whose lyrics
celebrate the exploits of drug
traffickers and it's an incredible drama
that takes place and involves a kind of
a border cop that goes bad makes a
reckless attempt at a hijack of some
mexican drug cartel cargo and it's an
incredibly powerful film the Academy
this is one hundred percent you know
changed my life this is amazing and
thank you so much for you know seeing
seeing something in the film I really
appreciate it went the a if I change my
life even more that made me the
filmmaker I I am today and just faculty
crew or faculty and the everyone there
was just instrumental so thank you I
skipped ahead to my crew crew wise you
know I million people but I I definitely
want to thank Jerry Ross Ross who wrote
the music and sang it and it's you know
he i mean the movies called narcocorrido
so you know he made the movie and yeah
fantastic ah my beautiful cast I mean
Nikki michelle rowe castillo he's here
Michael fan and meelo Rivera yep
Michael's here as well I the you know
coming on to a student film and putting
as much time into it and effort and
passion into it as you did you know it's
it was more than I ever could have asked
for and I definitely you know want to
continue down that path with you guys my
mic or filmmaking team like every day
you know pushed me to make what we made
together and we're going to continue to
make together on yay my producer
Benjamin kitchen is my cinematographer
on yahoo i'm gonna go ahead and make
sure if it's a the full name sorry yeah
well you know kelly andreadis and and
jared Shannon you know we've we the day
we shot we went up on the mountain and
you know we kept pushing through and we
haven't come down yet so i love you guys
thank you and my family my mom yeah who
doesn't love moms and but you know mines
better than everybody else's i love you
i love you and my wife Megan you know uh
gave everything came out here with me we
did this together i love you and thank
you thanks